ya trois personnes qui ne se connaissent
pas qui nous ont envoyé le même souhait
c'était pouvoir avoir le permis de
conduire portante et quand des personnes
nous demande d'avoir le permis de
conduire des gens qui en ont besoin des
gens qui ont besoin pour se déplacer on
avait entendu à priscilla qui nous
disait que c'était compliqué pour elle
parce qu'elle a pas moyen de s'offrir
les permis il ya madison 26 ans aussi
elle en a besoin pour trouver un emploi
plus facilement il ya houcine 18 ans qui
est étudiant en médecine y vit loin de
la fac
eh bien on a demandé à notre meilleur
est notre meilleur élément
c'est bien sûr isabelle morini c'est
très simple isabelle on va la retrouver
les temps duplex
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
isabelle vachiery est-ce que tu
m'entends mais ça pour vous entendre je
vous entends tu les as avant toute chose
je dois dire tout à fait je peux pas
faire est une jolie comme mathieu maye a
personne qui peut me voit rouge par les
touristes
isabelle isabelle j'ai une très grande
surprise pour toi mais les vidéos qu'on
a eues entre les vidéos qu'on a reçues
et le prime les personnes ne sont plus
là isabelle série j'aurais une très
belle surprise pour toi en plus c'est
vrai tout à l'heure et c'est vrai pour
l'un en attaque et a probablement tu vas
essayer de faire gagner le permis de
conduire sache que ton bandeau que tu as
sur la tête et une importance capitale
pour ce jeu le jeu est simple je vais te
poser des questions du code de la route
annaba j'ai pas trop nuque je vais donc
de poser des questions du code de la tu
vas avoir deux minutes pour y répondre
à chaque mauvaise réponse un tuyau on
remplira le véhicule dont on a vécu
qu'on a trouvé à la casse qu'on a refait
à notre manière voilà y'a plus rien
dedans y'a plus rien alors je vais me
poser des questions à la il va falloir
que tu donnes les bonnes réponses
d'accord ma chérie je te rappelle que tu
dois gagner tu veux gagner trois permis
ce soir mais elle est alors si je perds
tu vas leur donner quand même non
malheureusement non je ne pourrais pas
là je peux pas si avant la fin du chrono
l'eau dépasse la limite qui est ton
bandeau rouge
[Rires]
quoi
[Applaudissements]
malheureusement on est bien sûr d'y
arriver à une place de chroniqueur d'une
attention isabelle tu vas devoir
répondre elle en en deux minutes
non non elle lèvera pas la tête avoue à
12h30
c'est au play attention isama séries tu
me dis quand le prêtre est pas obligé de
dire la chérie chéri je me dis quand tu
es prête lui ménage qui va aller tu as
donc tu dois devra donner six bonnes
réponses sur 10 en deux minutes
même ses chantiers ces bonnes réponses
en deux minutes alors on faudra plus de
questions possibles comme ça voilà on
enlève les dix questions est d'accord ma
chérie est ce que tu es prêt à un rythme
bizarre faisons comme si attention c'est
facile première question une fois de
plus je crois jean-mi à la pompe
il met du sans-plomb 98 dans sa voiture
est une essence ou en diesel
98 de ces deux licences bien jouer
vendrait cause ciba il m'appelle patoche
au volant pour lui dire de mettre à
chauffer les boulettes que risque-t-elle
une amende
oui mais de combien ça 50 euros non non
135 euros d'amendé et un retrait de
trois prochains mois
c'est gentil tu les gentils c'est gentil
c'est gentil alain la légende aller il a
battu marat pizza man tu m'attends
toujours c'est que le début t'inquiète
pas mâché alors isabelle tonnes gynéco
souffle dans le ballon
il affiche 0,2 mg à combien de verres de
vin cela correspond-t-il
ouais 0,2 c'est pourquoi je vais énoncer
terrain vers laval à la raquette 10 a
pour l'instant tout va bien
ses valises à faire les eaux là bas ces
écoutes c'est chaud et vite new look
roady mémoire et en centre ville il le
plaquent sonne jiminy cricket études et
il en infraction si ils klaxonnent en
ville tu sais pas si les quatre seuls 6
janvier les passions vie les a arrêtés
on va les faire gagner un peu de temps
isabelle question il ya du brouillard et
comme castaldi sa vision est réduite à
moins de 50 mètres à quelle vitesse doit
rouler avec celle ci le détruire non
c'est 50 km à la voix
j'en ai salade a fait voir on l'attend
pour l'instant bloquée débat pour
l'instant c'est gagné
attention question isa sachant que va
bien le cadre mesurera marque havas 37
sachant que fabien lecoeuvre mesures à
mettre 30 sept
dois je y mettre un siège danseurs
[Applaudissements]
et si c'est oui car il mesure moins d'un
mètre cinquante ont empli sanaa
et d'ajouter je sors d'un dîner race
rare chez maxime dillies est flou à
combien et limiter la vitesse sur
l'autoroute on nous entend plus
malheureusement c'est perdu je pleure
pas ça bizarre
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
le vase sava ina question
je vois matthieu delormeau qui
s'engagent sur un passage piéton
j'accélère où je cède le passage ça va
arrête de respirer
on peut voir l'eau la dernière question
la question serait tombé à cette
question j'ai gagné là-bas
isabelle question sa voiture
gilles verdez écoute à fond à we always
pas tout à combien s'élève le monde est
là en tant qu est ce que tu as l a pas
entendu
elle prend l'eau isabelle sortez et
sortent ça n'allait pas et on vous
répondez vous aux rentrées
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les jeunes
elle s'appelle il s'appelle match c'est
non
[Applaudissements]
là
ils ont consacré à ma survie viens nous
rejoindre au sein de ma chérie et vous
gagnez d'autres permis de conduire je
suis là tous les trois le permis
elle a l'habitude des baignoires apporte
en même temps c'est plus facile à
saint-etienne